das sind die regeln
[Musik]
wir sprechen über einen film der für das
deutsche kino ganz ungewöhnlich ist der
deutsche zombiefilme würde man nun
wirklich nicht allzu viele aufzählen
können
und ich gebe sofort zu dass ich jetzt
auch schon fast einen fehler gemacht
habe
denn ganz streng genommen ist eigentlich
endzeit gar kein zombie film obwohl es
wie es mit einem film zu tun haben der
davon erzählt wie ein von zombies
befallener landstrich nicht befreit wird
sondern durch reist das gibt bereits
einen hinweis darauf dass wir hier etwas
ganz anderes haben als die üblichen
verfolgungsjagten und schrecklichen
horrorszene
in gewisser weise haben wir eine art
bildungsroman fast schon einen öko
thriller der im endeffekt die zombie
bedrohung der menschheit nur zum anlass
nimmt etwas über die verfasstheit des
menschen zu erzählen das klingt jetzt
unglaublich abgehoben und das mit dem
film auch wieder gar nicht gerecht denn
es ist eine ganz simple kleine
geschichte skurrilerweise sind nur zwei
städte auf der welt nicht von den
zombies befallen und da sind
ausgerechnet jena und weimar wer sich
ein bisschen thüringen auskennt weiß die
liegen sehr nahe beieinander und die
bahnstrecke dazwischen ist auch noch in
der hand der menschen und zwei junge
frauen kommen aus gründen über die ich
jetzt gar nichts weiter sagen will
auf diese bahnstrecke und der zug bleibt
mitten zwischen beiden städten stehen
klassische ausgangslage für zombiefilme
große bedrohung helden den verzweifelter
lage viele zombies um sie herum
aber was dann passiert ist eine art
selbstfindungsprozess den die beiden
frauen bei der flucht durch die
romantischen thüringer wälder hindurch
machen sie erkennen plötzlich das in
gewisser weise das heil des gesamten
planeten mit diesem zombies auf dem
spiel steht bei uns vermittelt wird dass
dieses ruhige leben in den wäldern wenn
sie eben nicht vor den zombies flüchten
müssen wenn sie zu sich selber finden
und die schönheit in dem erkennen was
sie umgibt dass das eine art anti droht
ein gegengift ist gegen die bedrohung
von außen und das kann man natürlich
sehr sehr gerne allegorisch betrachten
auch so ziemlich alle zustände dieser
welt und dieser film hat etwas
beruhigendes insofern an sich als er
hoffnung gibt dass wenn man es wagt
etwas anzutreten und sich dabei auf das
verlässt was um einen herum ist
und das nutzt was um einen herum ist
dass man dann tatsächlich etwas
ausrichten kann
das hast du vorher hat sie scheiße
gemacht ich glaube kameras verrät das
ende ist relativ offen aber genau darum
auch sehr hoffnungsfroh wenn man genau
weiß diese zwei frauen die werden jetzt
etwas beginnen von dem wir noch gar
nicht richtig wissen wohin es führt und
das ist unglaublich bemerkenswert nicht
zuletzt auch deshalb weil dieser film
fast ausschließlich von frauen
produziert worden ist wir haben eine
regisseurin caroline hals gott wir haben
zwei hauptdarstellerinnen die beiden
jungen frauen die ganz großartig agieren
wie haben eine fantastische kamerafrau
und das alleine zu sehen und das in
knapp 90 minuten ist eine unglaubliche
überraschung im deutschen kino eine ganz
große stärke hinein
jetzt müssen schon die schwächen heran
wovor man warten muss ist wirklich die
erwartung man würde jetzt ein spektakel
geladenen film sehen der unglaubliche
spannungs element oder so etwas erzeugt
das ist es überhaupt nicht das ist
wirklich ein psychologisch großartig
gearbeiteter film der offenkundig nicht
über viel mittel verfügt hat und sich
darum ganz auf seine akteure beschränken
musste natürlich tauchen zombies auf
aber das wird vor allem durch
schnitttechnik und ganz ganz schnell
gemachte szenen abgewickelt und darüber
hinaus gibt es keine herden von effekt
gesteuerten zombie armeen die die beiden
städte bedrohung gibt auch
dankenswerterweise keine besonders
extremen horrorszenen ich bin kein
freund des horrorfilms als solchen als
reine effekt film und das alles kann
dieser film sich sparen muss sich
wahrscheinlich auch sparen
darum die zombie liebhaber die sind
wahrscheinlich im alten im letzten jahr
muss film viel besser aufgehoben gewesen
wer aber etwas wirklich intelligentes im
deutschen kino sehen möchte dem empfehle
ich sie ja dort reinzugehen
die menschen hätten im paradies leben
können
sie haben ihre chance vertan